this network of alleys in pat pong
usually the vibrant center of bangkok's
unique style of nightlife now sits idle
and dark
the shutters were pulled down on bars
and entertainment venues in the weeks
after the first cases of covet 19 in
thailand and have stayed down for most
of the 18 months that followed thanks to
shutdowns and curfews
this part of chinatown is home to a
community of trendy small specialty bars
not only do bar owners view the
government's handling of their industry
during the pandemic as a near death blow
but alcohol control laws predating the
shutdowns have also been working against
them
i am embarrassed about this situation
thailand is renowned for its great
nightlife many bars here received
rewards
why doesn't the government support the
industry
i think these strange laws are supported
by big business to maintain their
monopoly
our voice is not loud like theirs
bar owners call the laws draconian in
which alcohol sales are limited to set
hours during the day heavy taxes on
imports and unequal laws only allowing
large companies to brew beer and distill
alcohol
a ban on alcohol advertising and
internet sales are so strictly enforced
bars were fined for posting videos of
cocktail making and menus for drinks
delivery
yet large breweries avoid the ban by
advertising mineral water and soda that
bear the same logos as their alcohol
products here's an example of thailand's
alcohol control laws if i were to take a
selfie here in this bar and share it on
social media i could be fined up to one
thousand five hundred dollars for
indirectly advertising the brands of
alcohol behind me if i own the bar i
could be fined up to fifteen thousand
dollars and possibly face a year in jail
alcohol control laws have been a
contentious subject in thailand
historically politically connected
conservative and religious groups have
worked to keep them strict
an opposition member of parliament a
former bar owner himself is working to
change the laws and save smaller bars in
trouble when really opened again
and the tories come again they would
find out thailand is complete completely
different country completely if not fun
anymore
yet some who support the alcohol laws
say it's also about safety for visitors
i think tourist safety should be a
priority i think alcohol control is
necessary if we let the alcohol sellers
run free and do whatever they want
things will get messy
once thailand emerges from its lockdown
curfews are lifted and the nightlife is
allowed to reopen it's unclear if it
will return as it once was or a
watered-down version
scott heidler al-jazeera bangkok